siccome lunedì abbiamo ri esplorato sony
camper humpers come si chiamava volevo
riportare una perla che non cessa mai di
esistere
purtroppo non so se ve lo ricordate qv
opi bene quando io ero piccolo e con
piccoli intendo avevo 18 anni andavo al
liceo io non ho mai fatto niente per
questo non avreste mai detto se non
durante leggere informatica giocare con
i miei compagni a cuvio p cos'è con lupi
è un gioco che funziona sul web e topi è
semplicemente un gioco non molto
intelligente ma vabbè dove tu sei questa
persona l'avevo portato agli inizi del
canto se questa persona qui e devi fare
i metri c'è un però questa persona è
talmente poco allenata e decisamente
troppo articolata che non riesce a fare
molto semplicemente questi mezzi devi
farlo schiacciando questi da phil che è
veramente un casino e ero bravissimo
durante le lezioni di informatica facevo
cose incredibili adesso no però vediamo
se riesco a farlo ragazzi e da un sacco
di tempo che non ci gioco qui non mi
ricordo assolutamente più niente allora
cooper muovere la gamba avanti ok il mio
record per ora è un metro che è
veramente ridicolizzante devi schiaccia
insieme determinati tasti ti muovi però
non mi dicono quali sono stati
determinati tasti soprattutto il perché
sto andando all'indietro ragazzi
incredibile che questo gioco sia ancora
inesistenza james ha tra l'altro tra
l'altro il tipo che ha fatto questo
gioco ora che ci penso e lo stesso che
ha fatto getting over it
cioè si è evoluto nei tempi cioè aveva
fatto sta roba qua per la scelta ha
detto vabbè facciamo un gioco dove uno
sta in una pentola e niente il genio che
ha fatto sta roba è lo stesso che ha
fatto che tingavert adesso capite perché
c'è penso che lo vediate perché io non
riesco a fare un metro ma neanche riesco
a fare più di un mese due record pià
piace andare piano seriamente loro piano
piano bravo no avanti
no no quella è la ballerina bravo 131 né
tra il risultato di tutto rispetto
mi ricordo una volta che ero riuscito a
fare anche 100 ve lo giuro non so come
provo fatto 100 me lo ricordo benissimo
piano piatti no no no
novità dalla parte opposta allora adesso
gioco per andare all'indietro vado in
avanti come hai visto aspetta la
piegatura della gamba secondo me devi
preso capito come alternare i tasti
aspettarsi molto tre metri dove siamo
qua le olimpiadi
cos'è star o esagerati usain bolt ma no
dai si è esagerato ma troppo se metto la
gamba avanti e lascio che l'altra gamba
calda
ragazzi ho fatto tre metri non penso di
poter fare più di così credo di essere
impossibilitato a fare più di così vado
quando si mette in assetto di guerra mi
bagno e bellissimo guardalo guardalo
mamma mia se riuscissi per caso ad
azzeccare quella zampata per terra
guarderò dai sono andato a con la testa
di arrivarci porca l'arca e non le sole
regole olimpioniche qua si parla di
professionismo mi vuoi far sognare
questo è pazzo dai ma dai
perché è perché ti fermi ogni tot e i
ragazzi ho capito più o meno come si più
o meno cioè già rispetto a prima
un netto miglioramento il training
funziona
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ehi
[Musica]
i siti che dista impegno
è tantissimo
venti metri
perché non so più che alle gambe sono
pazzo
come cosa ho fatto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e stato molto difficile però sono stato
molto bravo
cioè come ho fatto un imprudente
dall'inizio 22 metri mica amica soggioga
attori e non sarò mai bravo come un
tempo questo mi sembra ovvio però non si
può dire che io sia scarso almeno quello
so che questo gioco non è forti night
che peccato però non è male credo che
ninja non sappia fare meglio di me cioè
non lo vogliono anche sfidare glielo
risparmio è mio caro ninja se solo
sapesse giocare i giochi veri fare sti
soldi veri come faccio io guarda guarda
qua qua ra qua qua ra qua le skill cosa
servono e servono quando poi vabbè vabbè
ragazzi a parte la rovesciata di
cristiano direi che possiamo passare al
prossimo sempre come copi sempre dallo
stesso creatore non lo direste mai
esiste un'altra cosa incredibile
chiamata klopp che sarebbe cupi con un
cavallo di farvi vedere un attimo se ak
i tassi come sono i tasti va bene non ho
ben capito come come dovrebbe essere mai
possibile una roba del genere proprio
devo raggiungere quella ragazza lì in
basso
questo è l'obiettivo va bene ci
riproviamo
credo in realtà che questo quasi a il
sequel i gruppi non l'ho mai capito bene
però siccome lo stesso creatore ha visto
quindi aver creato un videogioco
migliore del mondo una certa età va dai
facciamolo con un cavallo lo stesso col
cavallo e credo che il successo sia
meritato
cioè non so quando ci mette ad arrivare
a quella tipa di però ci possono signori
vi dimostro che col tempo e gli iscritti
ho fatto un intruments della qualità
video ludica del gameplay bravino non
trovo il cavallo è possibile
ho fatto più metri col cavallo che con
l'altro il problema è che col cavallo è
difficile cadere di faccia perché sei su
un cavallo al galoppo vai troppo è dead
redemption più o meno le ragazze sono
arrivato a quasi a metà a livello non è
così difficile cioè non è data lo è sono
io che sono bravo a giocare a giochi
schifosi questo talento da quando sono
nato non semplice mai capito dai miei
video il mio dio mio dio sono pegaso
volo fermi è un po un cavallo
che aveva assunto delle pastiglie però
non vi deve importare questo sto bene
forse non troppi stimo ma sto bene
finché hd in avanti non è un problema
per me condotta del indietro perfetto
vai al galoppo fratello vai ma i
creatori di questo gioco che tra l'altro
è sempre lo stesso di getting over it la
mike è stato prima di finire perché
secondo me non si può fare semplicemente
cioè non è una questione di una
questione di non riuscirci tensione equa
muoio qua qua cadeau qua che la do a
prescindere quattro scali sia qua non lo
puoi non esiste il modo in cui si può
fare questa base non si fa questa parte
qua imporsi non puoi andare avanti
perché in kingspan del cavallo
all'indietro impossibile cioè l'unico
gioco che io sono riuscito a finire di
dipodi è stato gip gere però finito fi e
3g ecco il mio più grande traguardo
videoludico è stato gip perché circo
credo di essere qui pare che sono uscito
fino adesso non c'è un dubbio
credo di sì che alla fine c'era poi il
tesoro strano se si no
avevo messo una vita faccio un solo
tentativo e basta gli oli giocati tutti
i giochi di bennett lodi tranne getting
over i che anche quello sono riuscito
non si sa come a finire bene forse ne
faccio più di uno di tentativo alla fine
tutti i giochi di questa di che ha fatto
questa persona mi hanno reso una persona
migliore se ci penso
nel tempo che ho passato nella mesi
senza giocare a queste robe non posso
dire di essere più giocato di più grande
giocatore di forma non posso che
attualmente è quello che ti fa fare
piumone non posso dire di essere più
grandi giocatori di call of duty di
counter strike di rocket league ma posso
dire di aver finito giro
[Musica]
ma conteneva fatto su tiziano curiosità
curioso di vedere al cubo pil ha fatto
che ti ngo very little master cricket va
bene fai provare allora questo qua è
semplicemente dove che devi dare devi
tirare mazzate alle palle che arrivano
sono bravissimo 2 al punteggio sarebbe
quello lì sopra va bene è difficilissimo
vabbè in qualche modo spiega riesco
peraltro quanto è snodato sto tizio è
perfetto
ecco questi soldi sport che mi
piacerebbe fare a me quelli dove ti
snodi e basta perché tanto non di forza
nelle gambe non ce lo è perché c'è ma
neanche la posizione ottenere questo io
mi voglio vedere mangiare queste questi
atleti
io nei miei sogni più profondi mi
immagino il protagonista di klopp che un
cavallo di cubo piccolo di gir per
questo qui insieme che cenano e sono
tutti sempre snodati a no una palla
beccato l'altra 96 sono stato bravissimo
il mio obiettivo ragazzi arrivare a 100
poi posso concludere ed è difficilissimo
però lo so che ci possa arrivare a mio
dio ma dai 64 cosa è successo lì ragazzi
mi sta veramente impegnando scusatemi
porco tema 112 118 non solo fatto a fare
112 miracolo divino perfetto era
esattamente quello che cercava a posto
va bene non ce la farò mai più a fare
100 di ragazzi sono orgoglioso di me del
mio traguardo youtube i co spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto il mio obiettivo è
arrivare almeno a cento perché non c'è
non potevo sopportare un traguardo
peggiore spero che vi sia piaciuto come
al sole bisogna c'è un commento mi piace
anche se ho fatto una bella ricerca di
nuovo dei giochi vecchi che faceva ai
vecchi più o meno dei giochi belli
meglio ribelli che facevo quando ho
iniziato ho aperto il canale
sono contento che si siano evoluti tutti
questi in getting over
sono proprio contento però che riesca a
un musical di getting over it perché lo
farò sicuramente se non siete iscritti
iscrivetevi e noi come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo vinti da ragazzi
[Musica]